[Music]
yeah so back in 2004 I had a well pretty
much a trifecta of setbacks I first
broke my neck which was the best thing
that happened to me that year and I'll
explain that in a minute but I was in a
practice court in Rome and pretty much
laid headfirst into a net post and
fractured a c7 in my spine and got to
the hospital and eventually got home and
when I got home to Connecticut it was
the last six weeks of my father's life
he had been suffering from stomach
cancer and ended up passing away and so
that's why I say break my neck was the
best thing that happened to me because I
got to be home with my dad and spend
that time with him and say all the
things that needed to be said to him and
he wouldn't have let me come home
otherwise I don't think because I would
have still been on the road and and and
playing and competing and so that was
the best thing that happened to me and
after that stress has an amazing way of
bearing itself physically on me and it
created a zoster which is shingles and
attacked my facial nerve so I was left
on my face was paralyzed and lost my
balance and here a part of my hearing
and part of my eyesight so I was pretty
much struggling and didn't know if I
would ever play tennis again and doctors
weren't sure if I would ever play so
that's where setting goals day by day
was so important to me because if I
thought about the any sort of playing in
the US Open or getting back and being
top 10 in the world top 20 in the world
anything like that it would seem so far
away and I think I would have gotten a
little depressed that would have been
upset about the fact that I was so far
away from that so all I did was every
day think about what I can do a little
better I would try to move my eye a
little bit more try to be able to smile
a little bit more and go out on the
court the first times I went out on the
court it was really just being able to
see the ball when I toss it up to serve
it was just spending five minutes on the
court with my coach and just seeing if I
could actually make contact with the
ball and you know then the next day it
could be ten minutes and then okay now
you can take a couple days off because
it was disheartening now I need to get
back to it and try it and every day was
getting a little bit better and I still
member a friend of mine joking that well
you know what next year it's alright
you're going to win the US Open and I
thought you're absolutely crazy that's
not even in my mindset and before I knew
it the next year I was in the
quarterfinals of the US Open against
Andre Agassi I thought man I wonder if
he was right maybe I will actually win
the US Open this year and I didn't
unfortunately but the setback was was
such that I needed to focus on such
small goals every single day that if I
thought that the next year would have
been one of the best years of my life
and 2006 just two years later would have
been in my career the the best year of
my career by a longshot and finish at
number four in the world if I had
thought of that two years prior when I
was laid up and my face wasn't working I
I don't think I ever would have gotten
there I needed to just take small steps
every single day to reach that goal and
before I knew it when I was reaching
that goal I wasn't even thinking back to
all the hard work I was doing I was like
this is this is just the progression
this is where I belong this is where I
should be and I think that played a huge
part in it was just the process I was
taking to get there
[Music]
you